en Dublín.
(Risas)
Pero está en camino.
Esta es la última pieza.
Se trata de la supuesta llegada a la cima de todos nuestros esfuerzos.
En Santiago mismo,
podría ser Santiago,
podría ser La Meca,
podría ser Varanasi,
podría ser Kioto,
podría ser ese umbral que te has propuesto,
el enfoque perturbador para la consumación de todos tus objetivos.
Y una de las dificultades para entrar en la propia vida,
para entrar en este cuerpo,
en este mundo por completo,
es empezar a darse cuenta
de que has fabricado tres ilusiones perdurables
que el resto de la humanidad ha compartido desde el principio de los tiempos.
La primera ilusión es que de alguna manera se puede construir una vida
en la que uno no es vulnerable.
De alguna manera uno puede ser inmune a todas las dificultades
y enfermedades y pérdidas
a las que la humanidad ha estado sujeta desde el principio de los tiempos.
Si miramos el mundo natural,
no hay parte de ese mundo
que no pase por los ciclos del nacimiento, inicialmente,
o del ocultamiento,
y luego el crecimiento, la plenitud,
para comenzar entonces una maravillosa decadencia
y luego una desaparición muy austera y plena.
Miramos eso, decimos: "Es hermoso,
pero ¿puedo tener la primera mitad de la ecuación, por favor?
Y cuando ocurra la desaparición
cerraré los ojos y esperaré a que llegue el nuevo ciclo".
Lo que significa que la mayoría de los humanos están en guerra con la realidad
el 50 % del tiempo.
La identidad madura
es capaz de vivir el ciclo completo.
La segunda ilusión es,
construir una vida en la que no quiero romper mi corazón.
El romance es el primer lugar donde empezamos a hacerlo.
Al comienzo de un nuevo romance o un nuevo matrimonio,
uno dice: "He encontrado a la persona que no romperá mi corazón".
Lo siento;
uno la ha elegido inconscientemente justamente por esa exacta capacidad.
(Risas)
Te romperán el corazón.
¿Por qué?
Porque te preocupas por ellos.
Si uno mira la crianza, ¿sí?
"Seré la madre y el padre perfectos".
Tus hijos te romperán el corazón.
Y ni siquiera tienen que hacer nada espectacular o dramático.
Pero por lo general, hacen algo espectacular o dramático
(Risas)
para rompernos el corazón.
Y luego viven con Uds. como espías y saboteadores durante años,
viendo cada movimiento psicológico,
y detectando todas sus debilidades.
Y un día,
cuando tienen alrededor de 14 años de edad,
de espaldas a ellos,
en la cocina,
mientras que uno hace algo para ellos,
(Risas)
entra el estilete psicológico.
(Aplausos)
Y tú dices: "¿Cómo sabías exactamente dónde colocarlo?"
(Risas)
Y dicen:
"Te he estado observando
(Risas)
unos cuantos años.
Y esperamos que nuestras personalidades blindadas y profesionales
impidan que nos rompan el corazón en el trabajo.
Pero si uno es sincero sobre su trabajo,
debe romper su corazón.
Uno debe llegar a los umbrales
donde no sabe cómo proceder.
No sabe cómo pasar de aquí a allá.
¿Qué hace eso?
Nos pone en una relación apropiada con la realidad.
¿Por qué?
Porque uno tiene que pedir ayuda.
Angustia.
No tenemos una opción sobre la angustia,
solo tenemos la opción de que nos rompan el corazón
personas, cosas y proyectos que nos interesan profundamente.
Y la última ilusión es que
de alguna manera puedo planear lo suficiente y arreglar las cosas
que voy a poder ver el camino hacia el final
desde donde estoy de pie,
directo al horizonte.
Pero, si lo pensamos,
el único entorno en el que eso sería cierto
sería un desierto plano,
vacío de cualquier otra vida.
Pero incluso en un desierto plano,
la curvatura de la Tierra alejaría el camino.
Por lo tanto, no;
uno ve el camino,
y después no
y luego lo ve de nuevo.
Así que esto es Santiago,
la supuesta llegada,
que es una especie de retorno al principio todo al mismo tiempo.
Tenemos esta experiencia del viaje,
que está en todas nuestras grandes tradiciones espirituales,
de peregrinación.
Pero solo al estar realmente en el suelo de la vida,
y no absortos en un futuro estratégico
que en realidad es solo un escape de la angustia actual;
la capacidad de permanecer en el suelo de la vida
y mirar el horizonte que nos llama,
en ese momento,
uno es el viaje entero.
Uno es la conversación entera.
"Santiago".
"El camino visto, luego no visto
el camino visto, luego no visto
la ladera que se esconde y luego revela el camino que uno debe tomar
el camino que se aleja de ti
como si te dejara caminando en el aire,
y luego te atrapa,
te atrapa
y te sostiene cuando pensabas que caerías,
y te sostiene cuando pensabas que caerías.
Y el camino a seguir
el camino a seguir siempre, al final,
el camino por el que viniste,
el camino que seguiste, el camino que te llevó a tu futuro,
que te trajo a este lugar,
no importa si a veces te trajo una promesa,
no importa si siempre te partió el corazón en el camino:
el sentido
el sentido de haber caminado desde lo más profundo de ti mismo
hasta llegar a la revelación,
de haberte arriesgado
por algo que parecía estar dentro de ti y mucho más allá de ti,
te llevó de nuevo al final
al único camino que podías seguir,
caminando como lo hiciste, con tus harapos de amor
y hablando con una voz que por la noche se tornó oración por una llegada segura,
para que un día
te dieras cuenta
de que lo que querías que ocurriese realmente ya había ocurrido
hace mucho tiempo
y en la casa en que vivías antes de comenzar,
y que
y que cada paso en el camino,
en cada paso a lo largo del camino,
habías llevado el corazón, la mente y la promesa
que primero te expulsó y luego te atrajo,
y que
y que eras más maravilloso
en tu simple deseo de encontrar un camino
y eras más maravilloso en tu simple deseo de encontrar un camino
que los techos dorados de cualquier destino que pudieses alcanzar.
Eres más maravilloso en ese simple deseo de encontrar un camino
que los techos dorados de cualquier destino que pudieses alcanzar:
como si desde el principio
hubieses pensado el punto final como una ciudad con cúpulas doradas,
y multitudes exultantes,
y al doblar la esquina
en lo que pensabas que era el final del camino,
encontraste solo un simple reflejo,
y una clara revelación bajo el rostro que mira hacia atrás
y debajo de él otra invitación,
todo de un vistazo
todo de un vistazo:
como una persona
como una persona o un lugar que buscabas desde siempre
como una persona o un lugar que buscabas desde siempre,
como un audaz campo de libertad que te llevó más allá;
como otra vida
como otra vida,
y el camino
el camino que sigue extendiéndose".
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Muchas gracias. Gracias.
Muy amables. Gracias.
(Aplausos)